welcome to the lifespan podcast where we
discuss the science of aging and how to
be healthier at any stage of life
i'm david sinclair
i'm a professor of genetics at harvard
medical school and co-director of the
paul f glenn center
for biology of aging research
i'm joined by my lovely co-author and
co-host matthew laplante welcome matt i
love that you call me lovely
i think you are lovely you're nice
you're nice you can be nice sometimes
hey today in our episode we're going to
be talking about exercise
and other what you call adversity
mimetics
but before we get to that today
right after we stopped typing in the
last episode you went oh my god iron
um and then we had a really great
conversation about iron and so i wanted
to bring us back there before we could
move forward today is that all right
that'd be great i
so the last episode if anybody missed it
was about
the foods that we can eat or not eat or
not eat right to live a long time and it
was remiss of me not to bring up a
pernicious element
called iron
pernicious yeah it's uh
it's one of the elements that is is
turning out to be quite a dangerous
element to having or too much of in your
body increasingly we see that people who
have high levels of iron
have accelerated aging
okay yeah but but iron is essential
right we all need iron in fact people
supplement with iron a lot of times
right well we need iron it's a major
component of hemoglobin which carries
oxygen which we need
but the levels don't need to be as high
as we once thought in fact people who
live a long time and have these diets
that are recommended
i typically see they have lower levels
of iron and lower levels of hemoglobin
and this is not necessarily a bad thing
conversely people who have very high
levels either genetically
hemochromatosis or take a supplement and
end up with high levels of iron
might be predisposing themselves to
accelerated aging
okay so what about just
i mean this plays into your idea about
why people should limit their meat
intake though because meat intake meat
is high in iron but red meats especially
are higher that's one aspect but
typically if people are taking
multivitamin with high levels of iron
this could be a really bad thing it'll
accumulate in tissues and we know now
that particularly ferrous iron leads to
the production of free radicals that
damage tissues in the body and even
worse it leads to the accumulation of
these zombie cells which we call
senescence cells and those drive the
aging process in part large part because
they leech
these inflammatory molecules that cause
other cells in the vicinity
to become inflamed to age to sines and
even cause cancer
let's let's back up for a second here
because i think we're going to talk more
about senescent cells in a coming
episode but we have mentioned free
radicals before and i think uh that's a
word that gets thrown around a lot
um and maybe not everybody understands
free radicals right and we're not just
talking about people in portland oregon
or eugene or berkeley yeah so these are
free radicals that these have been
around for for millions of years of
course and we've known about them
for at least the last 70.
these are there are three main types of
free radicals there's the superoxide
uh molecule which is quite damaging it
can lead to what are called advanced
glycation end products which are
basically proteins that are damaged it's
one of the reasons you want to fast
sometimes during the day to get rid of
these damaged proteins there's a super
oxide anion it's called which creates
most of the oxidative stress in the body
and then there's a third one hydrogen
peroxide which you can buy a bottle of
and dye your hair blonde or or orange as
my hair went during the pandemic
those three things are really bad you
dyed your hair during the pandemic i got
bored just dyed it how did it look
horrible
it really went orange i've been dying it
ever since just to cover it up but it's
almost gone thank goodness but this is
this is where iron comes in when you
have a
superoxide molecule it'll be turned into
peroxide by an enzyme called superoxide
dismutase which is extremely important
to get rid of that superoxide which is
going to damage the cell but then you
get hydrogen peroxide and we know how
bad that is
look at my hair
it you don't want that circulating so
then what happens is there's a molecule
called glutathione which will turn that
into water but if you have too much iron
around
there won't be enough chance to detoxify
it and it'll be turned into
at this hydroxyl radical and that's a
really damaging molecule that goes on to
damage your dna your rna lipids proteins
and drive aging and senescence so you
want to have iron enough not to be
lethargic to have enough oxygen
transported but not super high levels
that will cause accelerated aging and
this is going to be different for
different people 10 of the population in
the united states has the uh hfe gene
which makes them more susceptible to
hemochromatosis which means they have to
be even more concerned
you can't know this without
knowing if you carry this gene though
right i mean
right you need do need to measure things
and that's why i
myself and i recommend people measure
their blood by chemistry and determine
whether their iron whether it's free
iron which is the worst type or even the
bound ion
are out of whack and you can correct for
that in the case of a normal person i
would say don't take an iron supplement
necessarily although women
may need it certain times of the month
but people who have hemochromatosis
they're particularly susceptible to
aging and the recommendation typically
of a doctor is donate blood if you can
okay so just to like go over what we
talked about last time really quickly um
you
uh advocate for a plant-based diet you
advocate for
low iron levels
what am i missing
well we're going to talk about that
today
what type of exercise works best i was
just talking about how we should eat but
yeah
well we left eat less often even less
often yeah so what i i've gone from not
eating breakfast now to not eating lunch
as well and just focus on dinner and
giving my body a rest from food
overnight and through the middle of the
day so that it turns on our defensive
genes against aging those three buckets
the mtor which senses amino acids or
lack thereof
uh the ampk which senses energy which is
glucose mainly and the sirtuins which i
work on
that sense all of those things including
exercise and those three
protective mechanisms we can turn on by
eating the right things eating less
often and exercising and this leads in
really well actually to what we're
talking about today because what we're
talking about is uh bringing your body
into a state of perceived adversity as a
way to turn on these genes before we can
do that
we've got some business to take care of
we do because this podcast comes to
everybody for free
we should definitely mention the
sponsors that make that possible our
first sponsor is athletic greens
athletic greens is a greens powder
developed from a complex blend of 75
vitamins minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients
it's filled with adaptogens for recovery
probiotics and digestive enzymes for gut
health
they also have vitamin c and zinc
citrate for immune support i've been
drinking athletic greens for a number of
years now i do that not just because it
tastes good but because i travel and i
often don't eat perfectly and by having
it every morning i rest assured that i'm
getting all of the vitamins and minerals
that i need for optimal health if you'd
like to try athletic greens you can go
to athleticgreens.com
sinclair to claim a special offer
they're giving five free travel packs
plus a year's supply of vitamin d3 for
immune support
and k2 which will keep the calcium out
of your arteries and put it into your
bones again go to athleticgreens.com
sinclair to claim this special offer
today's podcast is also brought to us by
levels
levels is an app that syncs with a
continuous glucose monitor or a cgm
which they provide
and that interprets your glucose data
for you
i've been so impressed with levels that
i've recently joined them as an advisor
monitoring your blood glucose levels
allows you to run experiments to see how
different foods impact you
i just did this myself a number of years
ago and i continue to do it
i've learned a lot about what kind of
foods i should avoid and which ones are
okay to eat
if you'd like to try levels you can skip
the 150 000 person wait list and join
today by going to levels dot link
forward slash sinclair that's levels dot
link
slash sinclair today's podcast is also
brought to us by insidetracker
insidetracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and your dna to help you
better understand your body and reach
your health goals
i've been using inside tracker for over
a decade over that time i've been able
to optimize my health and even
potentially get younger than my actual
age
they make it really easy you can have
somebody come to your house like i have
or you can go to a local lab the data is
easily uploaded by them and you can see
a dashboard on your body that also gives
you personalized recommendations for
exercise and nutrition
if you'd like to try inside tracker you
can visit insidetracker.com
forward slash sinclair and you'll get 25
percent off any inside tracker plan
use the code sinclair my last name at
the checkout all right so let's get into
this um in this episode we're talking
about some of the things that uh people
can do to create and mimic in their
lives the
biological adversity that's
more
conducive to better lifespans than
health spans we call these adversity
mimetics we call these that i mean like
when you say we call these that is like
you and i call them that because i know
we call them that but is it like is that
a term that scientists use that people
actually use right now we just made it
up you're just making it up yeah but
it's a good work right we'll use it
so so and the reason why adversity is
important ties back to this idea that
you've proposed of a survival circuit so
before we move forward in this let's
talk about the survival circuit um we
don't have to go way way back in history
not four billion years we'll come
forward in time a little bit yeah you
can't you can go back four billion years
and that's in the book
but we're going to start in the 1990s
with uh cynthia kenyon and her work on c
elegans that's a good starting point so
in the 1980s it was all about just free
radicals we didn't know that aging could
actually be controlled by any genes
certainly not single genes and cynthia
came along as a young graduate student
and looked for worms that would live
longer and she mutated them and found a
strain of worm a mutant worm that was
living twice as long
so instead of living for 15 days 30 days
and that was a remarkable finding
because when she
dissected the worms bred them out
found that it was due to a single gene
mutation
and when she cloned the gene and found
out where it was it was in a gene that
sensed insulin it's the insulin receptor
gene called daph2 that was remarkable
because it had nothing to do with free
radicals had nothing to do with dna
damage it was a signaling molecule
and that was the start of a revolution
in understanding how to control aging by
using genes and
supplements and drugs that turn on the
body's defenses and this was the first
so-called longevity gene
yeah i would say that was the first it
came very close to the work that we were
doing at mit um we were maybe a year
later than her but we you seem a little
annoyed by that not so much me i'm
careful because my supervisor lenny
guarente used to get really annoyed when
he was told that he was slightly behind
he thought his work was being done at
the same time so those two used to be
the
i guess maybe still are the at the
forefront of this field
um they're certainly the grandparents if
nothing else
and they both both showed uh so cynthia
and worms and then lenny and yeast where
i was at mit
made the finding that a single gene
alteration can have a huge impact on an
organism's lifespan and these genes are
there's a few of them now that we've
identified um and they all of them
seem to work on a very similar circuit
that all starts with adversity that's
right these signaling
proteins like the daf2 one that cynthia
discovered and the sortuans that we work
on
we didn't know what they were doing at
first i was like this is crazy it's got
nothing to do with dna repair and free
radicals but then when we tracked what
they were actually doing it turns out
they're speaking to
the rest of the cell
to keep the cell healthy and alive
so in the case of that worm those worms
weren't just longer lived the program to
survive was activated those worms are
stress resistant you can
hit them with heat you can hit them with
cold you can starve them
or just put them in happy conditions
they live longer this the paradigm is
that
normally a worm responds to its
environment if it's starved it'll hunker
down it'll survive but here we had a
worm that was mimicking starvation
and was able to have the benefits
without having having to starve itself
how how do these
genes for lack of a better word no how
do they know that
the conditions are adverse and they need
to turn on
uh well there are various sensors and so
the three main pathways
that control this we've talked about
mtor which is sensing the levels of
amino acids in the cell
lower levels of certain amino acids
branched chain amino acids
are good for the cell because they down
regulate mtor activity that's one way
the ampk senses energy glucose and then
the sirtuin sense nad which is a
molecule that goes up with exercise and
hunger together those are the sensors
now how does a cell communicate with
other cells well there's insulin like we
know when we eat a meal insulin goes
from our pancreas into our bloodstream
and tells the rest of the body hey
you've got sugar ready
suck it in use it
that's a signaling protein and what
cynthia's worms ended up
when they were mutated is that that
signal to bring in the glucose was
mutated
and this insulin signal was absent and
we don't have the insulin signaling and
you're a worm it means you're hungry and
you get the benefits of being hungry
without having having to starve
so our body is this always active
monitoring system we're perceiving the
world around us and the world around us
is constantly throwing different
stressors at us
um
[Music]
or at least it was in human history
right we've always
been a little cold or a little hungry or
a little scared or having to run from
this animal or that animal that wanted
to eat us this is the
environment that our species evolved in
that all species involved in right is
this constant state of adversity
right and that adversity we've evolved
to fight back
um and so in the past our bodies were
constantly fighting disease and
deterioration throughout life even
before birth we're fighting against
entropy
things are falling apart the aging clock
that we can now measure begins at
conception
but if you fast forward to now
our society is built on comfort
we've got most countries have enough
food and shelter
we can sit down we don't have to run
away from predators very often
and this is a real problem because these
longevity defenses that normally would
be activated by being cold and hungry
and running
are lethargic the body doesn't expend
energy to defend itself unless there's a
need for it and modern society is the
worst thing we've taken away those needs
yeah we love comfort it feels good but
that's the worst thing for long-term
health we need to trick the body into
getting out of its comfort zone by doing
these things we've talked about
eating the right foods including foods
that are stressed eating less often
which puts
stress on us which which causes our body
to feel like it needs to protect itself
because if we're not
filling it with all of the nutrients and
calories we want it perceives a need it
perceives adversity and it turns on
these these genes right and as long as
we have adequate nutrition that's why we
call it intermittent fasting with
adequate nutrition or ifan this is
another term we just coined in this
podcast
that allows the body to turn on these
defenses without suffering long-term
negative consequences what's interesting
i find is that even though we know the
fridge is probably full with food
our bodies are not that smart our bodies
don't get that message and we can trick
it trick the body into thinking oh my
goodness
the fridge is running out of food or the
field or the forest is lacking in food
we better get to hunger down and survive
what are those things you burn fat
you increase your metabolism so you've
got more energy to run around and find
food you become more alert because
you've got to go find more food
and you defend your body against insults
whether it's incoming infections or
diseases from within
and that's cool that we can trick our
bodies and it's not that hard we just
need to do the things we're talking
about on this podcast and and when we're
talking you know we've already talked
about like the the real key effects that
come from eating less often to basically
turn on this adversity memetic effect um
there's another really easy way to do
this though right and that's get off
your butt just get off your butt yeah
it's not that hard um as we say sitting
here doing this podcast but one way i do
it is i have a standing desk so my butt
actually atrophied when we were writing
this book lifespan
i ended up with
a cramp in my piriformis muscle which is
the way you're you're what yeah yeah
it's uh it's a small muscle
where is it the size doesn't matter
it's right in your hip it goes through
that hole in your pelvis
and it's essential for standing and it
was i wondered what that hole was for
yeah
it's there's a muscle that goes through
it yes okay all right and then so but it
was cramped up on my left hand side so i
was limping
for about nine months after we wrote the
book and i thought a great you know i'm
writing about health and longevity and
i've now crippled myself
i eventually got it to go away with a
combination of exercise physio and an
injection of nad in my butt which we'll
get to in probably the next episode
but the point here is that sitting down
is bad for us you atrophy
you have less muscle which means your
hormone levels especially particularly
testosterone will go down um and you
become
you know in pain that's not a good thing
but ultimately if you have not a lot of
muscle in your hips particularly you can
break your bones when you fall over when
you're older
and all of that means
you need to get off your butt stand up
even better go for a walk even better go
for a run or cycle to get what we call a
hypoxic state going your body needs to
suck in more oxygen and that has
remarkable health benefits and we really
have to work hard at this because i mean
you're saying this as we're sitting in
these chairs right a couple of days
after i sat down in a chair for a long
time in an airplane to get here right
we've got a nice comfy couch over there
that we've been working on
like we actually have to actively like
pursue opportunities to do this to get
this to get exercise to promote this
adversity mimetic effect because our
lives are built around comfort and
sedentaryness yes that's true and what i
think most people don't appreciate is
that exercise isn't just beneficial for
your fitness and for your vitality it
actually can stop diseases in their
tracks
exercise can slow down cancer in fact it
can prevent
up to 23 percent of all cancers from
occurring
that's true for cardiovascular disease
in fact it has an even bigger effect on
that 30 reduction just by doing moderate
exercise every week
50 minutes is sufficient
or three times a week with 10 minutes
all cause mortality right so what we are
all cause mortality is based mortality
is basically slowing down aging that's a
27 reduction in the rate of aging just
by exercising the thing you just said i
i love this idea of connecting the idea
of all-cost mortality with aging because
as we've
presented here as you've been arguing
for quite some time
um
most diseases um which bring us toward
the end of our lives are really just an
accumulation of the symptoms of aging
and so if you
bring down the disease rate
across various diseases which is
bringing down all-cause mortality
you're really just it's just an
another way of saying we're
bringing down aging we must be exactly
and we can also now measure that with
the biological clock the so-called
horvath clock named after my good friend
steve horvath
that is now a measure of the process
that leads to all of these diseases that
kill us and one way that we know for a
fact to slow down the ticking of that
biological clock is exercise and any
kind of exercise is good
um this is why the 10 000 steps a day
goal is popular um generally speaking
it's good it's not a magic number i
think there's
somebody came up with 10 000 and
[Music]
actually some studies have shown health
benefits that are
you know exist at four to six thousand
kind of peter out from there but but the
basic idea here is that when we move we
burn calories we're putting our bodies
into a at least a low state of adversity
right so try to get 4 000 and 10 000
seems to be
um even better it's a great goal it's
it's a round number it's fine get off
your ass that's what we're saying that's
all it takes it's not that hard walk
around the block a few times and
particularly after a meal as we spoke
about last time walking after a meal
gets your glucose levels to be more
level which is what you want which
relates to this we were talking about
this old chinese proverb like 99 steps
after a meal no a thousand steps after a
meal you'll live to 99 but walk after
you eat right because
well it'll stimulate the uptake of
glucose but also
it'll get your muscles moving and
stimulate the production of new blood
vessels make sure that you don't run out
of oxygen later in life but mostly what
happens when you move the first thing
that happens is a really important
reaction that involves one of these
longevity pathways the middle one that i
refer to called ampk and we can we can
turn on ampk just with a low level of
exercise just just start that adversity
yeah so ampk registers energy in the
cell which is chemical energy called atp
and when you have low levels of atp ampk
gets activated and it stands for amp
activated kinase and amp is what you get
a lot of when you don't have enough of
this fuel atp
long story short when you have high
levels of ampk activity
you will make more mitochondria which
gives you long lasting benefits so after
you've exercised your body will be
making more power more of these
[Music]
these organelles we call them that will
actually give you long-term health
benefits beyond the period of exercise
we
know that low-level exercise alone
is
good it's a good start um we also
know that it's really not enough you
need to also be getting a pretty
consistent dose of vigorous exercise too
it doesn't have to be a lot a lot of
these studies show you know 10 minutes a
day 15 minutes a day even even 15
minutes a week if you're getting started
is gonna have
health benefits but vigorous exercise
the easiest way to think about it is
your breathing your breathing rate goes
up and your heart rate goes up right
right and that there's a reason why
vigorous exercise is so important beyond
just just walking and standing
it's that you have hypoxia low levels of
oxygen
are undoubtedly good for you even though
they may not feel good um and when you
know you're you're hypoxic when you're
panting so much you can't cannot carry
out a conversation that's what you're
aiming for for at least 10 minutes a few
times a week so why is being out of
breath important
very rarely people ask that well the the
main reason because it doesn't seem to
make sense on a stage like you need
oxygen right so again it's this hormisos
idea a little bit of what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger so what's
happening is when you're hypoxic is
you're turning on
what's called hif1 alpha hypoxia
inducible factor and that pathway turns
on a bunch of really helpful genes that
control new blood vessel growth and
mitochondria
my
good friend and uh and colleague over at
harvard won the nobel prize in 2019 for
discovering hif1 alpha and its role in
biology
now the other thing that happens in that
there's two things so one is the f1
alpha that turns on a genetic program
that's good but what also happens is you
get free radicals generated because when
you don't have enough oxygen
those electrons that that should
normally be used by what's called the
electron transport chain in mitochondria
which generates atp
they fly out and they become a
superoxide radical can we can we talk
about that electron because it's really
fascinating how this thing works and
it's like it is a little circuit around
yeah it's a little it's a little battery
made of proteins and there's a string of
proteins that come together in the
membrane and they pass along a an
electron like a hot potato they don't
want to hold on to it they shove it
along get rid of it get rid of it and in
doing so they're pumping protons which
are hydrogen atoms into the inner
membrane space because there's two
membranes that surround the mitochondria
and in that little space
the goal is to make it really acidic by
putting these protons into there and
this electron transport chain does that
but you need oxygen because at the end
when you get to the end you've got to
get rid of this electron and they give
it to oxygen okay and then that's called
respiration it's reason we need to
breathe so hard when we when we uh when
we run and why we need oxygen in the
first place now if you don't have enough
oxygen then that'll lead to these free
radicals being produced and it'll damage
the cell
so you might say well that makes no
sense if you're running and you're
damaging the cell
it's going to be bad right but remember
a little bit of damage can be good so
what happens is it stimulates
what's called mitochormesis
mitochondrial hormesis and that has a
whole variety of benefits as well
including the manufacture of more
mitochondria that gives you energy
but i want to mention something that's
really interesting i think about this uh
electron transport chain remember how i
said those protons those hydrogens get
pumped into that little space to make it
acidic
so that now you've got what's called a
gradient you've got more of them in that
space than inside the mitochondria in
the in a bubble they have to they want
to get out they if they got too much
somewhere they should equilibrate and
what the cell does is it puts little
holes
that the protons can escape through a
little it's it's called the atp ace
and what happens is as those protons
shoot through it's like a hydroelectric
uh dam turbine and as they shoot through
it literally spins like a turbine
there's a little wheel at the bottom of
this tube that spins super fast many
times per second and that spinning
allows it to make atp or chemical energy
which then you use
then to burn to make the muscle
work
and so what's really interesting is that
the more mitochondria you have
if you've been exercising for a few
weeks allows you to make more chemical
energy and you don't feel puffed as much
as you did before and the other thing
that's happened besides having more
mitochondria is that you've built more
blood vessels in your body and so your
oxygen gets transported to the tissues
now both of those things go awry as we
get older and we'll talk later and
tomorrow about how you can
circumvent that and reverse your age to
be able to regain that ability with
drugs molecules and supplements besides
what we're talking about today exercise
itself yeah we keep going back to this
idea of uh a little bit of adversities
good for like a lot of is gonna a lot of
anything's gonna kill you but a little
bit of a lot of these things that might
in
big doses kill you is really good for us
because it puts our bodies into the
state of adversity let's talk about uh
this in terms of uh another
effect of exercise uh increased glucose
sensitivity right so as you get older
our muscles and our brain become less
sensitive to the insulin the pancreas is
putting out increasingly more and more
trying to cope with this insensitivity
that happens
now that's largely we think now because
of this aging biological clock that the
genes that are required for a muscle
cell to function or a brain cell to
function are getting switched on and off
in the wrong way we call this x
differentiation um and if you didn't see
episode one you might want to go back
and and hear more about that
basically cells are losing their
identity as they get older and not
putting out a particular protein called
glute4 which is a glucose transporter on
the outside of the cell so the muscles
are not bringing in the glucose there's
two problems right first of all you
don't have your energy to burn in the
mitochondria to make energy the other
problem is that that sugar that glucose
that circulates in your bloodstream and
doesn't get taken up into your muscle
and your brain
starts to damage the lining of the blood
vessels and we know that is type 2
diabetes and cardiovascular disease and
that's where veg
f comes in
so vegf is a little protein that signals
the formation of new blood vessels when
you exercise spelled this as vegf v
capital v e g f okay so if people want
to look this up then yeah yeah okay all
right so vegas so vegf is made by
muscles after you exercise you've gone
for your run or even your work but
running is even better and there's a
gene called pgc1 alpha that is what's
called a transcription factor it'll be
made it'll bind to
the upstream
side of the vegf gene and make more of
this vegf protein
now vegf will be secreted out of the
muscle
and diffuse or just leak out into
the lining of the blood vessels now the
lining of the blood vessels is made of
cells called endothelial cells which
pick up the signal they have little
receptors that sense vegef and when they
get that signal that says oh wow
we're being chased by a saber-toothed
tiger
for the last week we better build more
blood vessels and they do that normally
if you have a tube which is a capillary
almost microscopic um
blood vessels what happens is the
endothelial cells will start to branch
out to the side and make a new blood
vessel
and that's what you get with exercise
conversely if you sit around all day
you won't build new blood vessels you'll
actually if you have fewer and fewer and
your muscle and your brain start to get
starved of oxygen
now one of the big problems we
discovered is during aging that
signaling pathway that signaling
mechanism is defective
and even though you're exercising as you
get older you're not getting the
benefits of it you don't get the new
blood vessels and you can see this in a
mouse i mean when you take when when you
pull the mouse apart not to be too
graphic but you can actually see these
thinning
we don't even need to hurt the mouse to
see this we can use imaging to see the
blood flow in a mouse without hurting it
and we can see the bright red areas
where the blood's flowing nicely and in
an old mouse you don't get that
even with exercise but we found a way to
restore the youth of the muscle
and restore the ability of that vegf to
trigger new blood vessel formation and
the trick was to turn on the production
of nad which is the fuel for the sertuan
survival circuit
which can be turned on by exercise
because exercise up regulates nam pt
yeah also known as an mpt name pt some
people call it that but yeah this is
the relative of that ancient yeast gene
that we talked about in the first
episode
that extends life span of yeast cells so
let's add one more piece to this
um and that is uh how exercise impacts
the epigenome
yeah the epigenome if you missed episode
one i encourage you to go listen to that
and watch that because we covered what
the epigenome is and how it affects the
aging process
but the summary is that the epigenome uh
is the regulator of the dna it tells the
genes whether to be on and off and that
goes wrong during aging and may actually
be the reason we age and one of the
reasons we believe that is that you can
measure biological age now in people i
could take one of your cells matt back
to my lab i'll actually have to take a
chunk of your cells or a cheek swab
and we can measure the rate of your
aging
it's called the horvath clock or dna
methylation clock
and when you look at people that have
lived a healthy lifestyle
say they've been exercising for the last
30 years they are much younger
epigenetically according to this clock
than someone who hasn't
so that tells us that very likely that
exercise is not just protecting you
against cardiovascular disease it's
slowing down your overall rate of aging
there are other clocks as well um one
other many actually yeah so our one of
our researchers johnson was involved in
a study that used the proteomic clock
which works similarly let's talk about
that really quick because it's another
way to measure
biological aging right so you can
measure proteins in the blood which
change predictably over time
there's a protein called gdf15 which
is circulating it's now a really great
biomarker for aging
in fact gdp gdf15 is one of those genes
that was used in that study we referred
to last episode where the mediterranean
diet slowed the aging process they found
that gdf15 the methylation on that clock
marker was also slowed down
the point here being that these
proteomic clocks and the epigenetic
clocks and some others like an immuno
clock can be used now to
to understand what slows down aging but
importantly how do you reverse it with
various treatments and we've gone from a
field where we had no idea what was
going on in aging really we had to look
at
tens of thousands of people on metformin
to see if it helped health
to a point where we can take 100 people
treat them with something
two months later see if they've gotten
younger or not and those experiments are
being done right now and one of the
things we can treat them with is
exercise exercise in the study we're
just talking about
um they looked at aerobically active
people versus sedentary people and the
aerobically active people were five and
a half years younger on average
according to this proteomic biological
clock
presumably we'd see the same thing if we
used a horvath clock or an immuno clock
yeah and that's true actually it's been
done on exercised people and they are
also epigenetically young and what's
important about this clock to realize is
that it doesn't just tell your
biological age you can actually predict
when you're going to die or when
someone's going to die
and when i say that a lot some people
probably it's a little more people that
i don't want to know this well yeah
consider this that 80 of your future
health is in your own hands it's
it's modifiable 20 is genetic which you
can't do much about yet
that's powerful i mean
if you have the tools to change your
rate of aging
first of all you have to measure it to
know if it's working so i recommend that
and we'll talk about ways to do that
practically
but if if once you have that number
then
work with me
we can tell you here in the podcast how
to actually slow and reverse that
process
well we use car analogies a lot you and
i think a lot of people do these but it
bears mentioning like you know that your
car is not going to last forever
you there's a shelf life for any car
you get to choose based on how you treat
the car over time whether or not the car
is going to last a hundred thousand
miles or two hundred thousand miles or
three or four hundred thousand take it
to the body shop repair uh the mechanics
more often that's what we're talking
about for our bodies and that's why we
know we are important well you need to
measure it you need to know when the car
needs a service you need to know if
you're tweaking
that knob whether you're doing harm or
good
and
to that end one of the really cool and
exciting developments that's happening
right now is there's this sort of race
for
uh these clocks to become available
widely for people to use
um
[Music]
so much so that the the price point is
uh predicted to be
well like a buck well it's coming down
with the whole time for a horvath test
right so right now if you want to check
your biological age you can go to inside
tracker one of our kind sponsors
uh that's a that's a blood test or you
can also have a dna test which is
available by for a few hundred dollars
from various vendors
a student in my lab patrick griffin
we've posted recently a paper which can
be accessed accessed on bioarchive.org
that describes a way to pull
put together thousands of people samples
and run them all together bringing the
cost of that test down
to less than a dollar which is means
that very shortly in the future when we
bring out this product and we are
bringing it out soon you should be able
to do this test routinely and see
whether you try a new diet or a
supplement
or just meditation whether you're
actually benefiting from that
a lot of people hear all of this and
they go okay i get it i have to exercise
but and i hear this a lot but i hate to
run like everybody thinks that like
that's the only thing they're allowed to
do and and i think doctors making
physicians may contribute to this a
little bit by saying like okay well i
need to get you running and jogging and
whatever
it's not just running right like
what's the best kind of exercise well
there isn't
it's the exercise you're going to do
what you love doing
and it can be a sport
it could be
windsurfing it could be sailing but just
move that's the main thing there's even
there's even sex which is but
we we actually looked this up
we were really hopeful when we looked
this up but it burns like four calories
a minute or something it's it's not as
good as well i'm sure it depends on the
individual right i mean
you can make sex more aerobic
you can make it part of your exercise
regimen but you have to have a partner a
consenting willing partner who also
wants to make it part of their exercise
only 4.2 calories per minute which
on and we also looked up the average
length of
sex and it's about five minutes right so
you want to burn 20 calories if you're
an average person right i'll burn 10. so
in instead of that you probably need to
go for a longer walk afterwards to to
really burn off those calories and get
your blood flowing and however you get
your exercise be it running or sailing
apparently or sex uh both the world
health organization the mayo clinic
recommend at least 75 minutes of
vigorous exercise a week so that's
15 minutes a day 10 minutes and it's
better if you spread it out over the
week right yeah you don't don't do it
all at once um but that's that's the
starting point and most people can do
that you can be the busiest person in
the world you can be the most unhealthy
person in the world
you can get your heart rate and your
breathing up for 10 minutes a day
sure you can and the benefits will be
huge you'll feel better you'll look
better
and you'll also have a better resting
heart rate that's one of the best
measures of your fitness
if you're less than 50 for a resting
heart rate that's really good for
someone my age in my 50s my mind's
usually around mid-40s
that's a good indication of of how well
you're doing and if you've got a high
heart rate
it's you're either too stressed or
you're unfit try to bring that down
again you can measure your heart rate
pretty easily just put your hand on on
your arm but you could also either wear
a ring or a new fitness are these these
fitness centers
wearables now that are going to help you
do this yeah and i'm a big proponent of
measuring things right because otherwise
you're flying blind
so i wear a ring i wear a wrist uh watch
i sometimes i'm wearing right now
uh i am this is my also measures sleep
which we'll get to in another episode
but i also there are some advanced
biomonitors we're also going to cover
there's one that i stick on my chest for
two weeks that measures my body a
thousand times a second for various
parameters including my heart function
and in the future these will be used by
people to predict heart
attacks as well as the flu and all sorts
of issues like depression
in the future we're not gonna be flying
blind we're gonna be monitored a
thousand times a second as opposed to
now where you go to the doctor once a
year and they spend 15 minutes asking
you how do you feel which is a joke
right right um because in addition to
the fact that it's a single
it's a single assessment at a single
time it's highly subjective it's
self-reported it's just crap data yeah
this is a bit of an aside but it's worth
noting here that
i've been measuring myself for over 10
years using inside tracker and that data
is wonderful it's graphed and it you can
see when things go wrong i've corrected
that corrected it they do an inner age
study um there's a measure called inner
age 2.0 which tells you how you're doing
compared to others your age and you try
to keep that
low and based on that calculation i've
been getting younger for the last 10
years which is great to talk about but
it also means that i'm optimizing my
body every time
when i do something and if something
doesn't work then i won't do it and we
are going to get into this but i do want
to like i've got a friend nate price who
helps people do this at the institute
for assistant biology and um they uh
help people like create these charts
that they could then bring in to show
their doctors and he was telling me
about this woman who brought her chart
into the doctor and the doctor was at
first dismissive and she said well won't
you at least look at it and the doctor
looked at and went
oh wow this is really helpful
that's exactly the response of my doctor
too my doctor
said well how do you feel
you know i said i'm good i'm sleeping
well and he said okay see you next time
i said no hang on let's do some more
i've got some data can i show you and i
showed him the inside tracker data on
zoom and he said this is wonderful i
wish all my patients had this data of
course he cannot order 43 biomarkers
every time
the health insurance won't pay for it
but individuals if they want to spend
their money instead on instead of coffee
they can put it into a blood test
doctors actually do respect those data
because they're actually produced by the
same companies that the doctors would
use anyway and and to bring this all
back to tie this all back to exercise
and these other adversity mimetics which
we're gonna get to um having this data
i'm a big soccer fan the first time i
saw a soccer player trike off his shirt
he was wearing a bra and i thought what
the heck is going on but it's actually
holding these
trackers that are measuring things in
the middle of games in the middle of
practices the world's best athletes are
doing this right now and it's becoming
more and more available for other people
to track as well and once you have this
data you can start to act on this data
you can start to
uh
arrange your exercise routine so that
you're getting the most out of it
exactly and they can be fun too you can
use gps to see where you're going you
can compare it with your your colleagues
your friends i'm running more than you
let's move along here um because we've
got a lot more to talk about but before
we get away from exercise and start
talking about these other adversity
mimetics um
there's another form of exercise that i
know you enjoy that i enjoy a lot of
people enjoy but maybe doesn't get as
much attention as aerobic exercises
weight training i'm glad you said that
all right so weight training yeah i do
that
fairly often i would say at least uh
every other day if not every day
the way i do that is i have a gym in my
bedroom um i also have weights next to
my desk you also have them in the trunk
of your car right now i thought i do uh
it's because i
travel a lot so i'm taking weights with
me but the reason that i do weight
lifting is that it's going to maintain
my hormone levels it's going to maintain
my ability to walk well and stay upright
and have good posture it makes me look
better
although you may say that's debatable
yeah um but also as i get older it's not
debatable you're a really good looking
guy david thanks you're lovely matthew
thank you
the other thing is that that is often
not appreciated is it's harder to build
muscle as you get older
and you want to maintain that muscle
mass i'm losing about one percent of my
muscle mass every year unless i maintain
it or build it up
as you get older
you're going to fall over right everyone
falls over especially as they get older
and if you break your hip that's close
to a death sentence a lot of people
um well 19 people every minute fall over
and break their hip in the united states
which is a major cause of mortality and
the mortality rates after a hit break
just like skyrocket well it's equivalent
to having metastatic cancer that's how
bad it is but if you've got muscles and
you're flexible you do say pilates in
your older age and stretch build up the
muscles particularly around your waist
then you're much less likely to break a
bone when you fall yeah building muscle
mass also helps maintain youthful
hormone levels right so i had trouble
maintaining testosterone levels like
most men my age now there are two ways
to go about it generally
the main one is that your doctor will
give you an injection of testosterone to
to apply at home
or a cream you can rub on your forearm
those are the two ways you can do it
there are others but the other way which
i prefer
is to naturally boost it by maintaining
large muscles
exercising my thighs
my butt my back
and i've compared the two i have tried
cream on my arm for testosterone it
worked okay
my levels went up maybe by 20
wasn't great i
really maxed out my testosterone levels
by doing leg exercises and back
exercises i'm talking about things like
leg extensions leg curls
as well as hip hinge which is bending at
the hip and lifting weights um and i
also do deadlifts which is standing up
uh with lifting a really heavy weight uh
with a straight back
there's another way that we know that
exercise is impacting aging and we
talked about senescent cells in terms of
what iron
may be doing to
cause cells to go senescent but let's
let's talk about that as one of the key
aging what are called the aging
hallmarks
um exercise
prevents senescence it turns back
sentences what's exercise doing in in
terms of of these zombie cells
well you let's start with what a
senescent cell is so when the epigenome
becomes too dysregulated and this x
differentiation process happens
cells can either die
they can become a cancer but what the
body tries to do is to prevent that by
shutting these cells down and makes them
more like zombies they're alive but
they're not dividing and they're causing
havoc
and screening all these chemicals into
the bloodstream they are it's called the
sasp the senescence associated secretory
phenotype and these proteins
cause inflammation they also cause
cancer so the fewer senescent cells you
have in your body the better
and we're starting to find that there
that lifestyle and supplementation and
some drugs
can slow their formation
remember keep the iron levels low
but also we can kill them off
and there's this study the one you're
referring to which took 34 individuals
for a 12-week exercise program and
looked at the amount of senescent cells
circulating in their immunes in the
blood immune system
and it was dramatically lower in the
exercise people arguing that you can
actually
kill off or reverse that process 12
weeks just 12 weeks because these 12
weeks to like destroy some sentence and
cells seems like a pretty good deal yeah
it's one of the best ways to kill off
senescent cells that's the study that
was just out this year in uh aging cell
uh england at all we will link to that
in the show notes
let's
put a wrap on exercise but let's
have a few takeaways here and there's
really there's there's three big ones um
the first is a low level of exercise and
and this is just steps right get off
your butt get off your butt and dig yeah
standing desk or a desk with a treadmill
walk around the block after dinner or
lunch those are the simple things and
you don't have to hit 10 000 steps but
shoot four four four four is great yeah
okay all right and um then that's the
low intensity exercise that everybody
should be getting throughout the week
every single day you should also get
high intensity exercise for sure a few
times a week 10 or 15 minutes lose your
breath it can be the form of hit high
intensity interval training or running
on a treadmill that will get your blood
vessels flowing and your mitochondria
amplifying 10 to 15 minutes a day
yeah 75 minutes a week
yeah that that's what all the experts
recommend okay all right and then uh
muscle building yeah wait that's just as
important so maintain that muscle mass
for your hormones testosterone
particularly for men and women
exercise the big muscles particularly
don't forget about those don't just work
on your upper arms so you look good but
it's pretty simple you don't need a gym
in your bedroom like i do you can do
push-ups sit-ups uh or just have some
weights lying around that's sufficient
okay and all of this is the goal is it's
not just we want to look good we want to
write all of this is
aimed toward the goal of longevity
through
putting your longevity genes into or
alerting your genes your cells to a
state of adversity yeah the adversity
memetics diversity in minneapolis i
really do like this word i think this is
going to catch on yeah we trademarked
that one rob okay
so let's
but this is not the only exercise is not
the only adversity memetic there are
others we're going to talk now about a
few other uh categories we're going to
talk about cold temperatures we're going
to talk about heat
but there's a really exciting one right
now and it is related in some ways
through exercise or the effects the
genetic effects the the cellular effects
that we get from exercise
and it's really fast moving
the latest studies are only out in the
last couple of years and this is
hyperbaric oxygen treatment right or
hbot
yeah this is really fascinating because
for a while we knew that
wounds repair or heal faster when you
give them more oxygen because why
uh well it's not not clear it could be
hormesis um free radical generation
could be that more oxygen in the tissues
allows them to grow better
those are all theories but we know that
it works but then people started putting
themselves in hyperbaric chambers
the military certainly the navy have
been doing this for a long time
um to prevent uh the bends
but it's found to be quite therapeutic
particularly for neurological disorders
but increasingly for aging itself we
should say what a hyperbaric chamber is
right the hyperbaric chamber is a room
or sometimes just a little tube
where the uh pressure is increased and
when the pressure is increased the
amount of oxygen that you get when you
breathe is increased right you can go up
a couple of atmospheres or more and you
you supplement that with oxygen you
breathe in a bit more oxygen
um or pure oxygen and so i recently
tried this actually i went out to la
fortunately
unlike you i'm not claustrophobic i'm so
glad i can't do this i cannot do this
you probably can't but it's it's a glass
cylinder so you don't feel it and i just
watched shit's creek for a while it was
pretty cool especially when i was high
on oxygen you said it was funnier when
you it certainly was funnier but it
might just be because uh
every time i watch it it gets funnier
but but it's really relaxing i believe i
was in there for about an hour
and uh it was you know you can meditate
in there or you can fall asleep or watch
tv it's really a great experience but
that aside what the science says is that
it actually can reverse an aspect of
aging which is telomere shortening the
ends of the chromosomes many of us will
of you will have heard of this like the
ends of
the uh shoelaces the aglets they're
called if they wear out uh it actually
leads to cellulose senescence these
zombie cells and this happens over time
as we get older and what we've been
looking for we scientists for many years
is a molecule or a treatment that makes
them grow back again because that should
help slow down aging and give us longer
life and that's what was reported last
year from a group in israel who i know
well i've been over there and checked
out their giant chamber and you actually
got the wind of this before while they
were working on it and you went to kind
of like peek in on what they were doing
yeah i mean this is one of the fortunate
things about my
job is that i get to hear about things
before they're public and i get a sneak
preview and i went over there and sat in
their giant chamber which looks like the
inside of a bus
and with a mask you put on and they
showed me their data actually it looks
like a control room from star trek it's
really high tech and but the data that
they showed me in mice and in humans was
really compelling it looked like at
least in the mice that those plaques and
tangles in the brain of mice that were
given alzheimer's went away do you have
a little miniature hyperbaric chambers
for the mice uh we're building one
because i'm going to use one in my lab
but
they're not ready yet
but also what they were finding was that
the humans that were put in there that
had
uh dementia or parkinson's were
dramatically improved after a few
sessions of this
and it's become a real craze throughout
the us
a lot of this is happening in la where a
lot of these trends start
people are reporting remarkable benefits
now what we need are more studies like
the one in israel to actually measure
things and and if possible do a placebo
control as well but at least what we
have right now are some studies most of
them fairly small scale but but human
studies
memory
improvements uh telomeres t helper cells
right they go up as well so that in
cognitive performance there were six
elderly patients suffering from memory
loss and in 2021 this new study came out
and they all improved and the really
cool thing about this treatment even
though look like not everybody has
access to a hyperbaric chamber obviously
but it is a pretty easy intervention
and it's easy to
treat people this way it's easy to test
people in this way um so now we have the
clocks we have the clocks we can test if
if aging actually goes backwards that
would be a good experiment is to take
people who have done
seven or eight ten bouts of this
treatment before and after and see if
their biological age went backwards so
it's still early it seems like these
things are working across a variety of
ways that we can measure aging and the
problems of aging if this is working why
is it working yeah
well we don't know for sure but one of
the theories is that it's working
similar to exercise so hypoxia the low
oxygen when you go for a run what it's
doing is turning on this hif1 alpha
protein that i talked about earlier
and that
helps
promote health in the body
the other thing that happens with
exercise is the free radical generation
that gives you a little bit of
mitochormesis
it looks very much like hyperoxia
hyperbaric chamber treatment does the
very similar thing you get a production
of these free radicals
and that stimulates also a mito hormesis
response that gives you very similar
benefits to low oxygen
there's one theory that i have is that
when you come down from the high levels
of oxygen it stimulates simulates
hypoxia like you're running as you come
down from high levels to low levels so
it's not so much the oxygen that like
explosion of oxygen that you're getting
but it's like once you like temporarily
get used to that then
you come off of it's the differential
and that fits with the new findings
which is
going up once and coming down once is
not as good as going up and down and up
and down within a treatment before we
move away from uh hyperbaric oxygen
treatment uh i know you're most familiar
with this israeli study let's talk about
the protocol on that one
yeah they took 30 people and put them in
their large chamber the one that i
visited and they
did 60 daily sessions of 90 minutes five
of those per week and had a look at the
number of senescence cells in the
bloodstream before and after and
telomere length
and what they found remarkably was that
those aspects of aging were reversed
they saw uh impacts on senescent cells
too they did they looked at in the
immune system looking at looking at
these immune cells you can measure
senescence you can stain them blue uh
which is bright blue when you get older
and they found that there was a dramatic
reduction in the number of those
senescent cytotoxic t cells as they're
called okay so 60 sessions 90 minutes
this is not something anybody most
people can do every day right now this
is not going to be
a common part of people's
longevity regimens anytime soon well
there are a number of centers that are
run by doctors in major cities it'll
become more popular it's growing rapidly
but i think it's a great way
in the future for people to mimic
exercise
i wouldn't say don't exercise right but
it's it's an interesting idea that you
can lie down watch tv go to sleep and
get your your run in uh by mimicking
hypoxia but in this case with high
levels of oxygen in your body for a
short period of time it's really cool
let's shift now to talking about cold
therapy
which is another thing that a lot of
people are experimenting with now
another thing that there are centers for
all over the place but that the research
is still sort of catching up to the
excitement
um
so we're not
we're sort of on the edge here
of
our understanding but we do know some
things about
what coal does to the human body and
actually what coal does
to
organisms across the spectrum
yeah in fact when we wrote lifespan
there was almost no data on this but now
we know actually that one of the huge
benefits you get from being cold is the
production of brown fat so what what is
brown fat brown fat or
often called beige fat is found in
babies uh it's typically to allow them
to stay warm because they don't shiver
until they're about one year of age
and what was discovered about 10 years
ago at harvard
by bruce spigelman and ron khan a couple
of my colleagues is that adults also
have some brown fat
and they discovered this with with pet
scanning and they found it mostly exists
on your back uh in your shoulder blades
and when you get cold it revs up you get
more of this brown fat and this is a
good thing because brown fat is
extremely healthy it revs up metabolism
it burns
white fat
and we think that there are these
factors little chemicals little proteins
that get secreted out of brown fat that
make the rest of the body healthy as
well one of the reasons we know that is
because there's a gene that makes brown
fat make cells turn brown from white to
beige to brown and it's called prdm16
and mice that lack this gene
they don't have brown fat but they also
develop type 2 diabetes and
cardiovascular disease as a result
cold
impacts not just humans it impacts all
organisms
we've seen this in model organisms too
these effects right there's the studies
and worms there's been studies of mice
um you've got a couple of favorites i
know you like talking about the mice
that got the spoon together oh yeah so
that one is is a bit of a disappointment
in the field that we we had these dwarf
mice that mike bonkowski who was working
in my lab
he was the guy that generated the
longest lived mouse he called it yoda
and it was very long-lived because it
had a mutation in a gene
for the growth hormone receptor which
means they were small and dwarfs and
these little small dwarf mice would live
up to three times longer than a normal
mouse it was quite an amazing thing and
the field was rejoicing wow we figured
out how to make mammals live that much
longer and then it was noticed that they
were shivering with little cold mice and
so
the researchers thought we'll just give
them friends
they weren't shivering because the lab
was cold they were shivering because
they didn't have a companion you know
mice like to live not solitary but with
other mice
um and so they gave them a buddy each of
these dwarfs had a buddy and then the
majority of the lifespan extension went
away when they got their body yeah which
is super disappointing right but what it
told us was that
a large effect of longevity was due to
them being cold
and why is that happening when we go
back to like thinking about the survival
circuit what's happening
yeah well the trick is let's go back to
the brown fat what brown fat has a lot
of is mitochondria and within those
mitochondria
they're actually quite different they
have high levels of proteins called ucps
or uncoupling proteins which insert into
the membrane of the mitochondria and
allow those protons that were built up
to leak through instead of going through
that pump
that makes the energy they leak through
why is that interesting well first of
all that generates heat that helps the
animal and we survive cold but also you
get fewer free radicals produced when
you uncouple mitochondria with these
proteins
and
consistent with that if you make an
animal let's say it's a
worm or a fly or even a mouse that has
high levels of these ucp
genes
they actually live longer so uncoupling
and reducing that free radical load
and you can do this with cold therapy we
think is beneficial to health and cold
therapy
people call it cryo therapy um is this
like short-term acute
super intense you've done this before
right you did this with rogan didn't you
yeah yeah joe said uh let's go do that
after the show which i did um it was
pretty chilly i just had to strip down
into my down to my underwear and put
gloves on and socks and whatever but um
you get to play music at least uh i got
to choose help by the beatles which was
quite appropriate because by the end of
those three minutes you want it out well
the first two minutes i'm like what's
the problem this isn't cold but that
last minute
i really thought i was going to get
hypothermia and my ears might break off
you're chattering and shaking yeah you
really start to to shiver which is your
body's way of generating heat by moving
your muscles uh but it was it was really
enjoyable i found afterwards i felt
stimulated i felt lucky to be alive and
i felt good for a number of days
afterwards which is probably because my
mitochondria were revved up and i was
building more brown fat
the one thing i think it's worth pausing
here to talk about is
why would you do this now why don't you
wait till you're old to do cold therapy
and what's been found at least in mice
is that
old mice don't make brown fat as well as
young mice so what you want to do is
middle age do these treatments
and so that you're ready for old age
when it becomes harder just like right
now we need to be doing vigorous
exercise we can't wait until we're old
to do vigorous exercise yeah though it's
never too late we do find that things
work in elderly mice and elderly people
but it doesn't work as well if you start
mid-life or even earlier okay and maybe
that's like the cryotherapy stuff is
sort of akin to a vigorous exercise but
you still have to have that low level of
perceived adversity just like we have to
get like lots and lots of steps in every
day
um but we live in these environments
these temperature controlled
environments where it's like 68 to 72
that's not how our ancestors lived at
all no we were shivering probably most
of the time during the ice age for sure
and our bodies
recognize that we've got those genes
that respond and they keep us healthy as
we've talked about so there are a number
of ways you can if you don't have a
cryotherapy center near you what do you
do well you can take cold showers some
people do that i don't i find that
unpleasant but you can do that it's very
cheap to do that
or you can do something that i do
actually do which is sleep with very few
covers on my bed and lower down my body
temperature and that's also been shown
to activate these uncoupling proteins
and build brown fat
the opposite side of this is
heat which is also something that
throughout our evolutionary history
we've had to deal with we didn't always
live in temperature-controlled buildings
um and we're we've got some emerging
research on that as well right taking
your body out of its comfort zone and so
the
all of these things are about taking
your body out of its company yeah they
some of them are really enjoyable i
think sauna bathing is cold in europe is
super enjoyable um and it also is good
for your skin you get to sweat and get
get those pores unclogged but this is
one of the most ancient therapies for
longevity
even before roman times they were
bathing
in these saunas though the romans would
use fires under the under the floor
but this is something that europeans
still carry on as a tradition
particularly in finland and other
scandinavian countries where these
studies are typically performed
on men for some reason but the data that
i've looked at which will put the show
in the show notes is that there's
absolutely no doubt that men who partake
in sauna bathing a few times a week
often at home because they build this
into their houses
have a dramatic reduction up to 20 in
the rate of cardiovascular disease and
mortality caused by heart attacks this
isn't happening for the same reason as
cold therapy work this has nothing to do
with brown fat there's another thing
that's going on here right it's
different in this case what we think
goes on in a sauna is you're activating
hsps and these heat shock proteins are
helping to
fold proteins correctly and also
stimulate pathways that are beneficial
such as building new blood vessels
making more mitochondria and one of the
reasons that i believe it's true
is that in model organisms if
take a worm if you turn up these chalk
proteins
either by giving them a lot of heat or
genetically modifying them they also
live longer
we don't
quite know what dosing is right
for
sauna baths at this point or like how
much how hot
not a ton of research in this area
no but it doesn't seem like you can
overdo it i haven't seen any evidence
that it's negative um and i used to
before the pandemic i used to go at
least once a week and do multiple bouts
of
the heat shock in the sauna for about 15
minutes and then jump in an ice bath
which was nearby for four minutes and
then cycle that and you should probably
consult your doctor before you do that i
would definitely uh and i did
uh but yeah it can put some stress on
the body certainly on the heart but yet
the idea though is to shock the body
heat cold heat cold and that way you
have i think you get the maximum benefit
from these
adversity mimetics and again you don't
necessarily need to have access to asana
to do this i mean some people can build
them into their home some people have
them in their gyms that's kind of a
point of privilege most people have a
bath
or a shower or a hot shower i i
certainly do that i like to turn the
heat way up there are a variety of
different saunas there's the
old-fashioned type which is the cedar
planks sitting in there and you just
throw water on hot rocks that's
traditional there are new ones such as
infrared saunas and the infrared light
actually penetrates the skin and is
thought and there's some evidence of
real believable evidence that also in
the skin layer can reverse aspects of
aging as well and including
improve hair growth
there is um for some obvious reasons
there's a lot of questions i want to ask
about hair growth we're going to be
discussing hair growth skin care all
these like sort of like cosmetic aspects
of aging things in a future episode
one of the commonalities that i'm kind
of sensing in all of these things right
you you do vigorous exercise and you get
what you know we term a runner's high
and you talked about doing the
cryotherapy and you felt like what did
you say like blessed to be alive or um
i've done
sweats
and sweat lodges and you come out of
those things and it's just like
it's the best drug in the world
what what do you think why why are these
things so similar this happens in the
hyperbaric chamber too yeah yeah that's
one of the nice side effects that's when
you know
that you're doing a good longevity
protocol because what's happening at the
cellular level is those three main
defense pathways get turned on
but at the physiological level the
neurological level you're getting
endorphins as well and that's when you
know you've actually done the right
thing so
let's talk about a basic protocol uh
with the caveat that we always make
which is everybody's gonna be a little
bit different
but um if we're trying to get sort of
you know like uh exercise
cold heat and and uh hyperbaric
um
what are what's a good way to do that
we've already talked about the exercise
protocol actually i don't think we need
to reiterate that you need to exercise
get off your butt right cold heat and
hyperbaric yeah well as i mentioned i i
used to do and i will do again uh the
cycling of the heat and the cold
uh about five times during one day of
the week this was on a sunday with my
son benjamin but i would say more is
better there's no evidence that you can
overdo this
you could even do it every day if you
don't have access to a gym you can
always use your your house you can turn
down the temperature
um or you can use your shower
and that will work almost as well as as
dunking yourself into a cold bathtub
or you could do what
gabby reese and led hamilton do which is
uh shove us into an ice bath with
literally with ice in it i think that
you know you don't need to do that every
day
didn't you almost drowned uh i did but
that was that was different that was
hyper hypoxia what they do is they make
you do exercise
with weights at the bottom of a pool
below your height so you're underwater
and you have to jump up with those
weights to get a breath from there we're
not recommending that at this time
uh i think everybody should go knock on
their front door and do it with them uh
no it's
but you can get hypoxia from exercise
it's very similar
so we've talked about hot and cold the
hyperbaric is is more of an issue i
think a challenge there's not a lot of
these centers around and it's expensive
it's hundreds of dollars per treatment
but that's in the future i think that
that i wanted to mention that because
it's really interesting how it's so
similar to exercise and hypoxia at the
molecular level but for most people
right now that's out of reach but that's
not the only thing in the future there's
a lot of really cool things coming down
the path right now that are going to be
a fundamental part of people's lives
pretty soon we're going to be talking
about a lot of those in in upcoming
episodes we are and actually i think a
lot of people will be excited that we
can mimic
this adversity with molecules with pills
with injections
and we're going to talk about that in
the next episode in the next episode
yeah so next episode molecules
supplements longevity that's there's
going to be a lot yeah i'm excited about
this one because i get questions every
day about it and i think it's going to
be one of the most downloaded episodes
yeah i think a lot of people are going
to want to
i'm excited to dig in yeah okay cool
thanks for joining us this episode on
exercise and other forms of acute stress
if you're learning from and enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to it on
youtube apple podcast and spotify on
apple you have the opportunity to leave
up to a five star review
if you'd like to support us please check
out the sponsors we mentioned at the
start
we've partnered with companies we truly
believe in and they make this show
possible
we also have a patreon that's
patreon.com forward slash david sinclair
there you can support the show at any
level that you like thanks again and
we'll be back next week to discuss
supplements and molecules like nmn nr
resveratrol and how these impact
longevity